we're now going to derive the
work-energy principle we're going to do
so by using Newton's second law but we
are not going to consider it with
respect to time as what we've previously
done but we're now going to consider it
with respect to space so F equals MA and
we're going to take the X component of
that and now we're going to integrate
this so F X D a crime and it runs from X
prime equals x initial to some final
value and then over here we have we're
going to pull the M out M integral and
it also goes from some initial to some
final value and we have going to have a
X DX we have previously shown that this
integral here is one-half V final
squared minus V initial squared and if
we're going to plug this in here we're
going to get that this expression is
one-half M V final squared minus V
initial squared and you should recognize
this term this is the change in kinetic
energy and what we have here on the
other side this integral FX DX is
defined to be the work work done on the
system which we're going to call W and
that work done on system is its change
in kinetic energy so this is the work
energy principle